foreign
Whitney Elizabeth Houston now anybody in
her Circle or her family members they
called her nippy her daddy her daddy
gave you that nickname he used to call
he called her nippy used to call me
Newfie what do you think fans would be
most surprised to discover about Whitney
Houston
they'll be glad to know that I'm like
them just you know regular
actually wanted to you know let's go to
White Castles in a limousine so just a
lot of fun a lot of fun
she loved to swim she was almost like an
Olympic swimmer but these are all things
that people don't know
why would I do for fun as a I'm just
very peaceful I stayed home most of the
time
I was lazy as all you know what
she loved watching television she loved
sleeping I was planning on becoming a
teacher or a veterinarian but after
learning that I could sing it's into
your blood I guess I just never really
leave so
she was sincere about helping people she
had a huge heart
she fed people she clothed people she
helped send people to school to know the
Whitney that I know to know the Whitney
that I knew is to truly know that you
were blessed to know an amazing human
being before you ever got to the voice
if you got a chance to know her heart
that was something special do you want
to see some Lions today yeah
the Bronx Zoo
was desperately in need of some lion
cubs and I happen to know of some
I thought that I'd donate them to the
zoo
Whitney had one of the biggest hearts
she embraced the next generation of
singers I remember Brandy
talking about how emotional she became
when she first met with me
I'm happy this is Whitney Houston oh my
God
I love Monica and Brandi that was to
Whitney that was the the future of music
she would love others more than she
loved herself
when I was 18 I lost my grandmother I
lost I witnessed the suicide I lost my
cousin Whitney didn't call on the phone
three black trucks pulled up in the hood
and she jumped out
she's got security outside suited and
booted and she's pretty much giving them
the hand she was on tour when when I
lost my second eldest brother and we're
in the middle of the service and
everybody everybody goes to whistle you
know Whispering they're whispering and
I'm like what if it whisper it is with
me she is
somehow made it to Detroit Michigan made
it to the funeral and she's walking in
by herself
I remember being in a car accident and
Whitney she came over and I think she
she slept in my bed in the room with me
for two days she would not leave
you know
this Fame and the success thing Man it
comes and it goes you know you're hot
today and not tomorrow or you know that
kind of thing so it's it's important to
know that um you have family and friends
that love you for you and not because
you got a number one song on charts
the world remembers Whitney as the voice
her tragic passing came the night before
the Grammys a decade ago in 2012 but her
very first Grammy appearance that was
back in 1986. if I win that'll that'll
be something
yeah
I believe this I knew it was me because
Dion said Whitney would go on to win six
Grammys but a lot of people wonder where
did she keep them well at first you know
when she had her Mansion in New Jersey
she would encase them downstairs and now
since her passing
I keep them archived here in Georgia
this is her dress from her first Grammy
performance look at that look how tiny
she
when the granny goes to
I want to dance with somebody with me
Grammy number two came in 1988 but it
was really 1994 that was Whitney's year
she had four nominations she won three
Grammys that year and who can forget how
she opened the show
[Music]
12 was the last time the Grammys would
pay tribute to Whitney the day after her
passing Heavenly Father
thank you for sharing our sister Whitney
with us we need we love
we love
but we met Whitney long before she was a
grammy-winning superstar in fact she was
just 20 years old singing with Jermaine
Jackson a full year before she released
her debut album
[Music]
what everyone forgets about Whitney she
was a model before she was a singer
people in the modeling business really
never knew that I did sing
so when they found out that I did sing
it was like oh so besides that you can
sing so let's let's deal with that too
[Music]
[Applause]
God gave me something really great and
he doesn't give it to everybody
Whitney's gift was on full display when
she performed the national anthem at the
Super Bowl in 1991.
[Applause]
they wanted her to lip sync this song
she didn't want to do it
because she can't lips ain't good she
said I want it singing and she sang it
and she sang it
I kind of blocked everything out and I
kind of went to the Persian Gulf where
the fellas were
[Music]
it was for them that I I sang it for
[Music]
[Applause]
1991 was a huge year for Whitney you had
that Star-Spangled Banner moment and
then she started filming The Bodyguard
but a lot of people thought that's where
her acting career began it wasn't
one of Whitney's first acting gigs was
in 1985 on the Ricky Schroeder show
Silver Spoons
playing myself and I'm performing I'm
doing a video at this club I find that
it comes sort of naturally in a way I
mean being a performer
yeah I got
it first this is my first I mean you
haven't seen me in any movies have you
lately
[Music]
so the story behind The Bodyguard is
pretty incredible because Kevin Costner
called Whitney directly and said you are
the only person I can Envision playing
this role and if you don't accept this
part we're not going to make the movie
I thought that she was like really worth
it you know and in fact we postponed the
movie for a year which then said
everybody you're waiting a year for
someone that doesn't even know how to
act you know I said yeah we're going to
do that
foreign
intimate things to do I was like all
right well don't put your tongue in my
mouth first of all yeah
I did
I close my eyes and I
exhaled
I liked that there was finally going to
be a film about African-American women I
believe in you and me in the uh meetings
that we had there was talk about Julia
Roberts but Whitney made so much sense
for so many reasons Denzel corn at me
and he said Whitney you're gonna do this
movie you can sing gospel
I said tinsel you've never heard me sing
gospel you say yeah but I've heard your
mother
Boy you know you know how to get me good
right
Infinity
who are you
I'm your Fairy Godmother honey
she called me and asked me if I would be
Cinderella it flatters me really to have
someone who who loves me that much who
listens to me she listens to me intently
We're Gonna Leave You Now with Whitney
in her own words she will never be
forgotten ever and may she always rest
in power I think I was born to perform
hello good evening to the Roxy and the
Whitney Houston show yeah
yeah how frustrating is it to live out
of suitcase frustrating
it can be very frustrating if you
actually live in one
I don't live in a suitcase
I need to sing
I don't need a career
it's wonderful that I have one and it's
been very good to me I worked very hard
at it but I need my family more than I
need a career I open my mouth and
singing people took me in they received
me and I'm I'm grateful I really am
[Music]
foreign